Welcome back. As we mentioned at the conclusion of the previous lesson module,
the drive for extensibility in operating system services led to innovations in
the internal structure of operating systems
and dynamic loading of operating system
modules in modern operating systems. And do not stop there. In this lesson,
we will see how the concept of virtualization has taken the vision
of extensibility to a whole new
level. Namely, allowing the simultaneous co-existence of
entire operating systems on top of the same hardware platform. Strap your
seatbelts and get ready for an exciting ride. Before we look deep into
the nuts and bolts of virtualization, let's cover some basics.